These days, Hollywood seems to operate under
the premise that you can never have too much
of a good thing.
If people like a film, well, that means you
can expect a dozen sequels to be announced.
But sometimes things don't go as expected.
Here's a look at some planned trilogies that,
sadly, will never be completed.
Hellboy
If there's an unmade sequel out there that
fans truly want to see, it's Hellboy III.
Guillermo del Toro's Hellboy II: The Golden
Army was released in July 2008, starring Ron
Perlman as the not-quite-horned-hero.
It received overwhelmingly positive reviews
from critics and grossed over $160 million
worldwide on an estimated $85 million production
budget.
But even though the movie was a modest success
for del Toro, it wasn't a monster hit.
So Universal Pictures never commissioned a
third installment.
Since then, both del Toro and Perlman have
publicly lobbied to make a third Hellboy,
but nothing has come of it.
Still, hope springs eternal.
In January of 2017, del Toro asked his Twitter
followers to weigh in on the possibility of
a third Hellboy movie.
After getting more than 132,000 responses,
del Toro and Perlman approached Hellboy creator
Mike Mignola to discuss the possibility of
a third film.
But there have been plenty of hopeful meetings
before, and after nearly a decade of waiting,
it's starting to look like this one will never
actually happen.
Amazing Spider-Man
Despite critics and audiences largely detesting
Sam Raimi's Spider-Man 3, Tobey Maguire at
least got the chance to conclude his Spider-Man
trilogy.
That's something Andrew Garfield will never
get to do, because in 2015 Sony Pictures suspended
plans to expand the Amazing Spider-Man franchise
and instead opted to share the character with
Marvel Studios.
As a result, we now have Tom Holland playing
a new Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and a rebooted Spider-Man film series that
officially kicks off with Spider-Man: Homecoming
in 2017.
But what were Sony's original plans?
Prior to Marc Webb's The Amazing Spider-Man
2 in 2014, Sony planned to launch an extended
Spider-Man franchise to compete with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
It was going to include two more Amazing Spider-Man
films, as well as spin-offs for Venom and
the Sinister Six.
Sony also hired Westworld co-creator Lisa
Joy Nolan to write a script for a female superhero
movie set in their Spider-Man universe, but
nothing has since come of it.
Although the studio canceled plans to pursue
more Amazing Spider-Man films, they haven't
shuttered all the Spider-Man spinoff films.
In March 2016, Sony confirmed they were moving
forward with the Venom film.
However, there don't appear to be plans to
have the movie connect to either the Amazing
Spider-Man films or the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"So, to become an Avenger, are there like,
trials, or…"
"Just don't do anything I would do.
And definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do.
There's a little gray area in there and that's
where you operate."
National Treasure
Jon Turteltaub's lowbrow take on Indiana Jones
was a surprise hit in 2004, and the 2007 sequel
National Treasure: Book of Secrets performed
even better, bringing in almost $460 million
worldwide.
The success prompted Disney to commission
a sequel the following year, and with the
studio acquiring domain names for National
Treasure 3 and 4, rumors began to spread that
the Mouse House was eyeing back-to-back sequels.
Although Turtletaub was interested in making
another National Treasure film, he said they
were going to take their time and get the
story right before moving forward, explaining
in an interview, "[U]ntil we have a great
story, a great adventure and a great piece
of history to explore, there's no point in
making the movie."
A decade later, it still hasn't happened.
TRON
It took almost 30 years, but in 2010 Disney
finally released a sequel to their 1982 cult
classic TRON.
Starring Garrett Hedlund, Olivia Wilde, and
Jeff Bridges, TRON: Legacy earned average
critic reviews and modest box office success.
It wasn't a failure, but it wasn't a big enough
hit for Disney to move forward with a third
film.
But the thing is, TRON: Legacy writers Edward
Kitsis and Adam Horowitz had already begun
working on a script for a third film before
Legacy even released.
Not long after Legacy hit, Ain't It Cool News
reported that Disney was gearing up to announce
TRON 3 — but the announcement never arrived.
Instead, after five years of dragging their
feet, Disney finally announced the series
was dead.
But hey, who knows?
Maybe they'll bring it back again in thirty
more years.
Kick-Ass
Director Matthew Vaughn and star Aaron Taylor-Johnson
brought the comic book series Kick-Ass to
life on the big screen in 2008.
Praised for its adult themes, Kick-Ass received
positive reviews from critics and managed
to become a modest box office success, prompting
Universal to move forward with a sequel.
Kick-Ass 2, meanwhile, was released in August
2013 to negative reviews and declining box
office sales.
Shortly before the release of Kick-Ass 2,
the comic book's writer confirmed that plans
for a third movie would largely depend upon
how much money the second movie earned.
Later that month, reports of plans for a third
installment surfaced, saying Kick-Ass 3 would
conclude the Kick-Ass trilogy with a major
death.
After the film's disappointing results, though,
those plans were put on hold along with a
rumored Hit Girl prequel.
That... does not kick ass.
28 Months Later
Five years after Danny Boyle's 28 Days Later
hit theaters, the sequel 28 Weeks Later arrived,
depicting a NATO takeover of the U.K., where
they supposedly quelled a zombie infestation.
Unfortunately, one person infected with the
virus survived and managed to spread it to
the remaining survivors.
At the end of the movie, a handful of survivors
escape England and make it to France.
However, one of them was still a carrier for
the infection, allowing the infection to spread
across the channel, ending the film on a cliffhanger.
Shortly after 28 Weeks Later released, Boyle
indicated that plans for a third installment
were in the works.
Unfortunately, screenwriter Alex Garland believes
the rumored 28 Months Later movie won't happen
due to copyright issues: "When we made 28
Days Later, the rights were frozen between
a group of people who are no longer talking
to each other."
Still, Garland and Boyle are still talking
about doing a third film, if those legal issues
can ever get resolved.
We'll see.
Ghostbusters
The first Ghostbusters movie ranks as one
of the most beloved films in history.
In fact, the U.S. Library of Congress selected
the original Ghostbusters for preservation
in the National Film Registry in 2015 for
being "culturally, historically, or aesthetically
significant."
It became a worldwide phenomenon following
its 1984 release, which prompted Columbia
Pictures to commission a sequel.
And while Ghostbusters II wasn't as well received
by critics as the first movie, it was still
a hit, earning over $215 million worldwide
on an estimated $37 million production budget.
"We came, we saw, we kicked its ass!"
Despite the success, however, director Ivan
Reitman didn't have any immediate plans to
make a third installment.
Flash forward 10 years, and series star and
writer Dan Aykroyd finished a 122-page draft
for Ghostbusters 3: Hellbent.
It appeared that they were finally making
progress on a third film, but Bill Murray
was reportedly uninterested in making another
Ghostbusters.
It was then rumored that Ben Stiller could
replace Murray in the sequel, alongside Aykroyd
and Harold Ramis.
"Venkman!
What happened, are you okay?!"
"He slimed me."
Nothing came of the idea, though.
And after the death of Egon-actor Harold Ramis
in 2014, Reitman officially backed out of
directing Ghostbusters 3, though he agreed
to stay on as a producer.
After approaching a few directors, Sony decided
to move forward with a soft reboot of the
franchise instead.
Without Ramis, it looks as though the original
team has busted its last ghost.
Regardless of the controversy surrounding
the 2016 reboot, at least there were seven
seasons of The Real Ghostbusters, one season
of Extreme Ghostbusters, and 2009's Ghostbusters:
The Video Game that tell more stories featuring
our favorite paranormal investigators and
eliminators.
Fantastic Four
After achieving global success with the X-Men
series, 20th Century Fox hoped to build off
those movies' hype by moving forward with
a Fantastic Four series.
The first Fantastic Four movie released in
2005 to mixed reviews.
However, fan anticipation led the Fantastic
Four to become a box office success, earning
over three times its production budget.
That success inevitably led Fox to commission
a sequel, titled Fantastic Four: Rise of the
Silver Surfer.
Director Tim Story and the rest of the cast
and crew all returned for the 2007 follow-up.
But it was meh at best, earning mixed reviews
and mediocre box office.
Story wanted to move forward with a third
film, but Fox decided against it, opting instead
to put the franchise on hold before eventually
rebooting it in 2015 with Josh Trank.
Of course, that move backfired, well, fantastically.
The new version became a critical punching
bag and a box office disaster.
Should have stuck with the original after
all...
"That's gross."
Kill Bill
Quentin Tarantino likes to make a single story
at a time, moving from one project to another
without thinking about sequels.
However, just a few short months prior to
Kill Bill releasing in theaters, Tarantino
and Miramax concluded that his four-hour film
would have to be split into two releases.
Thus Kill Bill: Volume 1 and Kill Bill: Volume
2 were born.
Although they aren't his most commercially
successful films, the series has become a
cult hit in the years since its release.
The second film ends on an unexpected up note,
with Beatrix and her daughter heading off
to live a life of peace.
However, Tarantino believes there's always
room for more.
In 2004, he indicated plans to make a Volume
3 with Uma Thurman reprising her role as the
Bride, though he said he would probably wait
around 15 years before making another one.
"You and I have unfinished business."
"Baby… you ain't kidding."
Over the next few years, Tarantino hinted
he still had plans to make a third Kill Bill,
with the story potentially focusing on "the
revenge of two killers whose arms and eyes
were hacked by Uma Thurman in the first stories,"
or maybe a revenge story featuring the daughter
of Vernita Green turning the tables and hunting
down Thurman.
But nothing ever came of either idea.
In 2012, Tarantino finally conceded: "I don't
know if there's ever going to be a Kill Bill
Vol. 3."
And that, of course, led Tarantino's fans
to do this:
(screaming)
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!